as a hip-hop head yourself who are you
like obviously you got benny uh on on
the project i mean
you got some other legends on the album
um
but who are you a fan of right they say
we got knives on the album oh i don't
know listen i don't wanna
be good okay so you got knives on the
outside yeah so we got nines uzi
the weekend uh no not we can't say that
oh okay so bleep that
uh the weekend now i'll let you tell
everyone who you're comfortable with
the telling who's on the album because i
don't yeah yeah yeah so we got the
weekend in nas
it's a joint called die for it okay so
yeah so they're on the same song
together
all right cool we can talk songs [ __ ]
crazy thank you it's [ __ ] crazy
and we shot the video i'll show you the
video
uh we were talking like yo this [ __ ] got
to be like victory type video like oh
man
yeah i think uh you know it's an
incredible visual bro like it's it's
just
it really looks like a movie i'm real
obviously benny
yeah yeah the show uh money bag yo um
yeah money bag yo um
man i got able again on another joint
yes
but you know that'll come out he's on a
total of
three nah the third one is just he's
just doing better no
but he's on there though but he's just
doing the background focus because i
remember when i heard it you're like yo
that's him doing background vocals i'm
like bro you gotta you gotta burn your
arm three times technically that's
pretty crazy
yeah man this is super dope
what was it like um like
wrapping up on a song with nas because
that is scary yeah that's got to be
scary right
you know like obviously it's a [ __ ]
one of the biggest honors of my life
of course [ __ ] you know what i mean
somebody that i've learned from
and respected and looked up to you know
half my life so
but it's scary man it's like
i hope knives don't wash me on this [ __ ]
you know that's that's really how i felt
and um my verse was there it was already
done
by the time i sent it you know so you're
you had to
send your verse in like because some
people will you know they might get the
nos verse back and they might revisit
their verse
that's that's that's against the rules
okay yeah so that's the unwritten rules
but some people do that
shout out to you remember uh ll did that
on the 4321 joint and that's how the
whole cannabis should happen
i didn't even know that yeah but nah so
so when you got naza's verse back where
you like
i held my own i mean man i'm
i'm just i'm just glad he did what he
did on it man he killed that [ __ ] and i
think for me
it's all i think it's gonna cut through
no matter what because it's like a
personal verse you know what i mean
it's like some real i talk about some
real things and i think
that's always going to cut through you
know i mean people are always going to
feel that type of thing so
first time the weekend and nods have
done a record together yeah yeah
amazing